Thanks. I'm losing it, but it's what's
left of it is still working on right.
And we're live. Gentlemen. Hello Sean.
Hey, how are you? Hello Tom. Hello Joseph.
What's cool? You guys did a movie.
Did you make a movie? We made a movie.
Did you guys do movies? We
do. We're moving. Guys. How
many movies have you made?
A one. Well, I bet you've made. How many
of you made before? I like six, but yeah,
but we've made one. We made one.
Yeah. What's your favorite one?
Other than the one that's right now?
Which is definitely your favorite cause
you're promoting it right now. Uh,
sex drive. Sex drive is the
one. Nobody knows about it.
Nobody knows about it. I mean, it just,
it was one of those movies that just
opened and nobody knew about it,
but it was a, it was a really, really
fun movies. Maybe we can change that.
It's on iTunes or Netflix. Yeah. Yeah.
It's all are James Marsden's in it?
This is the one. Is this the one that you
like when you made it? You're like, ed,
maybe I'll go back to working fucking
construction or whatever. Yeah.
So I thought, I thought it was over after
that. Did you finance it or anything? No,
no. We made it, um, we made it with
summit pictures and it was, it was,
it was just amazing. They, they, uh, we
were in town trying to get a career going,
you know,
try and try and make things happen.
We were making a TV pilot at the time,
which was a living hell. And, uh,
and we had gone out and pitch this idea
to a bunch of places and nobody bought
it. So then in the middle
of our, uh, editing,
our pilot summit pictures
called and said, um, we really,
we keep thinking about that pitch.
Would you guys be willing to write it?
And I said, you know what, tell
him I was really busy. I said,
tell him I'll write it if I can direct it.
But I figured that would make them
go away. And they said, all right.
And so we went in and we wrote it and
we turned it in and they green lit it.
It was this crazy,
it was just this crazy process where
we've got this movie green lit and I think
we wrote the draft and like a month. Then
we turned it in and they, they loved it.
And they said about, it's a, it's a, it's
a teen road trip movie. It's about this,
these kids that, uh, it was kind of
in the early days of the, you know,
Facebook and all that stuff. And it
might've even been, I don't know,
I can never track the, it might've even
been like sort of my space into Facebook,
that era, you know. Um,
but it was about a kid who meets a girl
online and goes to lose his virginity on
a, on a road trip. It's funny.
It is funny. Yeah. Marzano in it.
James Marsden, he's really funny. Clark
Duke. And um, I had a good cast and ah,
there it is. Yeah. Wow. Good. Um,
but it was a really great experience.
It was really fun. And then we, we,
we tested it, we did the test
screenings and it just murdered,
like it was just the, and the studio got
really excited. And I thought, oh my God,
like I'm going to have a huge career.
And then movie came out and didn't do
anything I need to do any business at all.
It was like, okay, I'm going
to go back to Wisconsin and,
and not have a career at all.
So is it true that instant family,
you hired Tom Because Bert Kreischer
wasn't available? Yes. The damaged,
don't tell me that, man. That's what
I heard. Well, and he was asking,
he was asking for a lot of money, a lot
more than where it is. It's lofty with,
it's like he's like, whatever
Mark's gets, I want double up.
And then they were like,
we can't do it.